(cheering)
It's everyone's dream to go very fast
on the German autobahn.
Well there it is. Right there.
And here I am with a rally driver from BMW
named Lars, hi Lars.
Hi.
And this amazing car, the BMW i8.
(whooping)
Start with your foot!
Aye aye aye aye aye!
I will help you!
(laughter)
Oh, good, good.
(accordion music)
Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
Lars, this car does not seem like the kind
of car that you would
use to drop your kids off
at school, right?
This car feels more like a car
that you would drop your
third wife off at school.
Do you ever pick up
hitchhikers on the road, Lars?
Sorry?
Hitchhikers, you know,
people looking for a free ride
by the side of the road.
Yes, okay okay.
Do you know what we do in my country
with hitchhikers?
No.
We murder them.
(laughter)
(singing in German)
Does that make sense to you? That song?
No, but it sounds
(claps)
Hey! Hands on the
wheel! Hands on the wheel!
Now we are allowed to drive fast.
Okay, now we can go as
fast as we want, right?
Yes.
Punch it, Lars! Yes!
Now it's 174,
185,
193.
Oh yeah!
That's amazing,
210, 215.
Yes!
Oh, I just had an orgasm,
did you have an orgasm?
No.
You didn't?
Well your orgasm is so
efficient and German, it's silent.
(laughter)
(accordion music)
I'm about to drive, take over.
How do you feel about that? You okay?
Okay, so it'll be fine.
Conan, this is an autobahn.
On the autobahn, you can drive faster.
The trucks are overtaking us. Aye aye aye.
We're being passed by
trucks on the autobahn!
You tell me when I can merge.
(dramatic music)
Wow, 150!
We got to 150. I know
that's not so impressive,
but there's a lot of traffic right now.
How do you yell in German at this man?
(curses in German)
(curses in German), asshole!
(laughter)
Now we go!
(clapping, cheering)
Guten tag! Um, could I have,
what would you like? Do
you want a milkshake?
Yes.
We're driving on the autobahn.
This is a sexy car.
Does the car make me sexy?
She's not, she just thinks I'm an idiot.
Where are we going? How fast?
Careful of the cars.
Oh, right. You're
getting a little nervous,
aren't you?
Yes, I'm really nervous.
You know why you're nervous?
No?
You didn't have as much beer for lunch
as I did.
160,
180,
90,
200!
We are 200!
(cheering, clapping)
Oh my god.
220.
230!
(screams)
(dramatic music)
(clapping, laughter)